We are going to be speaking with Stephanie
Kelton, who's a professor of public policy
and economics at Stony Brook University and
one of the world's leading experts in modern
monetary theory, unfortunately, due to a technical
issue, as I would call it.
We lost the first bit of the conversation
with her.
So I'm introducing her to you now and we're
going to join the conversation in progress.
If if Mitch McConnell and the Republicans
have decided that, you know, the four bills
that have been passed so far, that's enough.
That's sufficient.
We're going to close up and go home.
We're not going to do anything that's going
to add to the deficit further.
We're beginning to worry about the debt.
And you're going to see state and local governments
out to dry.
You're going to you know, there's a number
of other things.
But I have to tell you, that's the one that
concerns me the most, because you're already
hearing governors tell you they're very candid
about what the consequences will be if they
don't get aid from the federal government.
They're going to start cutting the public
workforce, firefighters, teachers, police
officers, essential services.
Everything is going to be cut and it's going
to be cut deeply.
They're going to be 20 percent, 30 percent
cuts, more lay offs.
And so what Congress is trying to do to put
some kind of a floor under the slowdown and,
you know, to provide some support for this
economy is going to be completely undone.
When you get 50 little Herbert Hoover's running
around all over this country, working with
their state legislatures to slash budgets.
So now along those lines, we the unemployment
insurance system.
These are state systems which are being there
independently operated.
Some you know, you file by phone, some Web
site.
The systems are sort of functioning to different
degrees, depending on how overwhelmed and
modern they are.
We've got the federal supplements for unemployment
insurance of up to six hundred dollars a week.
We're starting to hear that there are state
governors saying we can only really maintain
the state benefits for so long before those
run out, as they say.
What is your perspective on what needs to
be done in that sense?
Well, a couple of things.
The the mistakes have already been made in
the sense that once you allow people to become
unemployed, then the way that you're left
to deal with them is through unemployment
insurance.
And the the thing that happened after the
Great Recession, you probably remember, is
that people who went on unemployment insurance
then had the unemployment insurance.
That period of time runs out and then it expires.
And now you don't have anything.
And then you have to go back and Congress
has to fight and negotiate and pass a small
extension.
And then it turns out not to be long enough.
And you got all these people who became long
term unemployed, 26 weeks and more.
Many people were jobless for a year or more
in that environment.
And the benefits run out and all of the associated
problems.
So it would have been.
I just want to say I would have been much,
much better to have an effective paycheck
protection program in place that allowed employers
to keep hold of their workers, keep them on
payroll, avoid letting them slide into unemployment,
and then have this system, which as you describe,
is antiquated.
You've got people who are reporting that they've
made a thousand phone calls a day to try to
apply to get in the queue for unemployment
insurance.
So you know what happens when it runs out?
Well, I guess we we hope for the best in terms
of Congress being willing to extend unemployment
insurance as needed or people are just going
to be left with with no income at all.
And that's fundamentally I mean, that's how
it would have to be managed, right?
It would have to be managed where the Treasury
says we are going to fund these state programs
or we will make up anything that the states
are unable to pay.
That's the mechanism.
Right.
And as we've just been.
Yeah.
That's exactly right.
If what you have is a situation where the
federal government sits in a unique position
as the issuer of the currency, it can't run
out of money.
State and local governments, completely different
state local governments can't issue the U.S.
dollar.
They are users of the currency, which is why
every mayor and every governor essentially
is pleading with the federal government to
come through with grants, with aid to help
state and local governments because their
budgets don't work like the federal budget.
And so that's exactly right.
In an environment where revenues are collapsing
at the state and local level and state, local
governments are dependent on tax revenue to
pay the bills, whereas the federal government
is in, the federal government's going to have
to step up and write the check or we're going
to end up in a situation where you have mass
layoffs across the country, state public sector
workers and essentially states that are unable
to bear the burden of supporting the unemployment
insurance system.
I read a paper yesterday that argues that.
This is actually going to be much worse than
last, much longer than certainly the administration
is willing to admit when they say it's going
to go up like a rocket.
Analogies to Great Depression number two.
My question to you is, what are the indicators
we should be paying attention to to determine
whether that's the direction we're going or
whether in six or eight months there could
be a significant portion of the losses recovered.
I mean, I think we're watching the unemployment
rate.
I think that, you know, you you can extend
loans and say that they turn into grants,
but you're still we are still relying on businesses
to apply for these loans to take some risk
because it doesn't cover all of their fixed
operating costs.
We're essentially saying, you know, do us
a favor, help us keep people on payroll, but
we're going to cover some of your fixed costs,
but not all of your fixed costs through this
profit, through this process.
So businesses that have let a lease, they
have rent, they have utilities, they have
other fixed costs that they can't cover because
they're shut down.
They don't have any cash flow.
Right.
They have no revenue.
They're not going to take those loans and
keep the workers on payroll.
If it means they also have to incur a bunch
of other costs that won't be covered.
That's going to come out of their bottom line.
So watch the unemployment rate and watch how
many of these businesses are essentially going
to be gone forever.
And that's the really scary thing.
Small businesses really are the backbone of
our economy in terms of, you know, supporting
jobs.
And, you know, I I've talked with people.
I got a friend out in Kansas City and he said
a few weeks ago, you could drive around and
you could see signs in the business storefronts
that said temporarily closed.
Right.
He went back a few days ago and he said the
signs no longer say that.
They just say out of business, you know, they're
boarding up, they're going under.
So I think those are the kind of indicators
that let you know that the kind of thing that
you just said, that this could be orders of
magnitude worse than the Great Recession and
we could end up with an economy that is deeply
depressed for a long, long period of time.
Yeah.
Here in Boston, we've seen a shift from open
for takeout and delivery to closed until further
notice, which is sort of another since that.
Couple other things just to talk briefly about
before I let you go.
One is the stock market looking at the level
of the Dow?
Tell us anything relevant right now.
Well, it tells you a little bit.
I suppose it tells you that investors feel.
Let OK.
OK.
About the degree of commitment on the part
of the Fed to help maintain stock market prices.
I mean, I think it's a reflection of not so
much fundamentals, what we'd call economic
fundamentals and the health of our firms and
the likelihood of a solid recovery in the
months ahead.
But sort of confidence and a belief that at
the end of the day, the Fed the Fed has your
back.
I guess the question is whether that means
anything for Main Street, as they like to
say.
Because at a quick glance, you see the unemployment
numbers and you see the stock market doing
OK.
It doesn't make sense.
Now, a lot of that is how bad was it expected
to get when people go on unemployment?
They do presumably get some money which they
can spend, which could prop up stock market.
There are other factors, but how directly
does it relate to the average person's experience
and outlook?
Not very directly at all.
Yeah.
I mean, that's that's the thing.
I think investors really are mostly channeling
optimism about how far the Fed is going to
be willing to go to do whatever it takes to
protect the largest publicly traded companies
and shareholders.
Last thing, universal basic income.
There is a movement now, so universal basic
income, I guess as prominent as it has ever
been, probably mostly thanks to Andrew Yang's
candidacy in the Democratic primary.
There are a lot of conversations now which
seem to go along the lines of, hey, we clearly
can afford to do what Andrew Yang suggested
and we've clearly determined it's a good idea.
We being, I guess, you know, our legislators,
lawmakers, others saying there's really nothing
here.
These are extenuating emergency circumstances.
These are one time payments, even if it's
renewed one more time.
This is not universal basic income and it
does not affect the economy in the way that
a UBI would.
What can we glean about UBI from this, if
anything?
Well, I mean, the twelve hundred dollar check.
A lot of people are saying just keep that
going and that would be a form of, you know,
a basic income payment.
Yeah, I get even with the twelve hundred dollar
check, there is means testing.
Not everybody is going to receive that check
with the Yang proposal.
Remember that, you know, that proposal was
tied to a whole series of if then.
So if you want to opt into this program, then
check the math and make sure that if you're
receiving other forms of public support, if
you're on food stamps or, you know, there
were a range of public programs that if you're
a beneficiary, you need to decide whether
you want to continue to receive those benefits
or let those benefits go and take essentially
what's behind door number two with although
I think later on it became changed to be additive,
although I don't know why you're not remembering.
No, no, no, no.
It was additive in in the sense that if you're
not on any government program.
OK.
You get it if you are on certain government
programs like Social Security.
It was additive to that, but it wasn't additive
to the whole package.
Got it.
Good programs.
OK.
So but look, a basic income right now or an
income supplement to people makes perfect
sense to me.
Makes perfect sense to me in this moment that
you need to get cash into people's hands.
You've got all these cars.
You've got thousands and thousands of cars
of people, families lining up at the food
banks.
Right.
People aren't at the food bank because the
grocery store is out of food.
They're at the food bank because the bank
account is out of money.
And so in in this situation, direct payments
on a recurring basis for a period of time
make make perfect sense to me.
You don't necessarily think this tells us
anything about the long term idea of UBI?
No, not really, I mean, look, if we just did
this conversation where I said suppose we
were in the fall of twenty nineteen.
Yes.
If we're in the fall of twenty nineteen and
we were talking about sending every person
in this country which there is a proposal.
Congress, Congresswoman Rushford athlete has
a proposal to send.
I think it's two thousand dollars.
Right.
Every single person in this country for a
period of time.
Now that's a universal basic income payment
over a period of time.
Suppose we had talked about doing that in
the fall of last year when the unemployment
rate was three and a half percent.
And I think that most people would have said
there's your inflation invitation.
Right.
Because that economic environment.
People had jobs.
People were already have had income to spend.
And on top of that, you're going to layer
for eight thousand per household, depending
on the number of people in that.
I think it's a very different question in
that economic environment.
We've been speaking with Stephanie Kelton,
professor of public policy and economics at
Stony Brook University.
Stephanie, really appreciate your time once
again.
Thanks for having me.